so can you take us back to that day i
mean was it like an instant decision
once you had that conversation with him
or did you think it out in terms of
actually sitting down and flushing it
all out
you know at the time i was working odd
jobs and i also had a janitorial
business like when i was young that's
all i did was was the janitorial
work and going through those hardships
it it really it was like an up and down
do i want to make a movie i've never
done a movie and the more i kept reading
about it and i picked up this book
called documentary
and it was like from the 1960s and it
talked about
how to bring the awareness to
not only the people but to legislators
to to the the lawmakers the policy
people and
that's what i think really kind of
sparked me it was like i wasn't making a
movie you know to be entertaining as
much as i wanted to make a movie to
bring awareness of something that was
happening to people
can you take us back to what was going
on in your own life i know you touched
on it briefly but when you had this
conversation and then that turning point
where were you
in your own life with your own situation
regarding you know it was just it was
like you know
not understanding how to be a parent
how to do things and where to start
um you know the way i grew up uh was
very hard also so it was it was all like
this learning experience that came all
at once and
i just felt like you know
what could be the first step in
in the process every day and i just i
was at a point where
i had some pain
i had some
some misunderstanding of things i didn't
understand why laws were certain ways
against the non-custodial parents were
which were usually men and
it kind of made like it was a human
rights thing where i wanted to give all
i had as far as what i could teach and i
wasn't able to
and so
i just turned that around that feel
those feelings to where i wanted to
share it with other people and when i
found there was other people in that
position
i think it got easier for me it got like
okay i'm on this path
and that's what started evolving so i
kind of was
all these emotions were turning into
a positive thing
you